trusting teams
I went on a business trip to Las Vegas
and they put me up at the Four Seasons
out there which is a beautiful hotel
and one of the reasons It's a Wonderful
hotel is not because of the fancy beds
any hotel can buy a fancy bed
the reason the Four Seasons is a
fantastic hotel is because of the people
who work there
that when you roam the halls and
somebody says hello you get the distinct
feeling that they wanted to say hello
not that they were told to say hello
we're highly tuned social animals we can
tell the difference it's like we can
always tell when someone's working on
commission right you can kind of feel it
right we can tell the difference when
somebody's genuinely being friendly or
not
they happen to have a
coffee bar in the lobby there the Four
Seasons in Las Vegas and one afternoon I
went and bought myself a cup of coffee
and there was a barista working that day
named Noah
no it was funny and engaging Charming I
spent far too long standing there buying
my cup of coffee because I just so
enjoyed talking to Noah
so as is my nature I asked Noah a
question I said do you like your job and
without skipping a beat Noah said I love
my job now in my line of business that's
significant because like is rational I
like the people I work with I like the
job I like the challenge I get paid well
I like my job love is emotional it's a
higher order connection do you love your
wife I like her a lot right there's
there's a difference
Noah said I love my job my ears perked
up
he has an emotional connection to this
company this is interesting
so I immediately follow up and I said
tell me specifically
what the Four Seasons is doing that you
would say to me you love your job
without skipping a beat Noah said that
throughout the day managers will walk
past him and ask him how he's doing ask
them does anything that he needs to do
his job better not just his manager any
manager
and then he also said I also work at
Caesar's Palace and there the managers
walked past us and catch us when we're
doing things wrong and make sure that
we're making the numbers and Performing
and there I like to just keep my head
below the radar and get through the day
and collect my paycheck he said only at
the Four Seasons do I feel I can be
myself
this is the exact same human being and
yet the customer service experience that
we would have meeting him at one hotel
or the other will be profoundly
different not because of the person but
because of the leaders because the
leadership environment in which he's
been asked to work
I get this question all the time Simon
how do we get the most out of our people
they're not a towel we don't ring them
out to see how much we can get out of
our people it's a flawed question
which means we're going to get flawed
answers
the correct question is how do we create
an environment in which our people can
work at their natural best
and the answers will be profoundly
different
if you do not have trusting teams
what you do have is a group of people
who show up to work every single day
lying hiding and faking
remember a trusting team is when people
feel safe it's a trusting team is when
people feel they can be vulnerable
amongst their own they can raise their
hand and say I made a mistake
or you've promoted me to a position
where I don't really know what to do
I think I need more training
or I'm having troubles at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared
or I need help
without any fear of humiliation without
any fear of Retribution
in fact they say these things with
confidence that their leader their boss
their colleagues were rushed to them to
support them
if you do not have trusting teams what
you have is a group of people who show
up to work every day who will hide
mistakes for fear of getting in trouble
they will not admit that you've promoted
them to a position and they actually
have no clue what they're doing they're
going to just keep faking it
they would never tell you that they're
suffering undue stress because of
something that's happening at home and
that it's affecting their work they're
not going to tell you that they're
scared and they're definitely not going
to ask for help for fear that they will
find themselves on some short list for
the next round of redundancies
and eventually cracks will show up
and eventually the organization will
break
not because of the people but because of
the leaders leading those people
we know what this looks like in the
extreme I'm sure you all remember a
couple of years ago United Airlines had
an incident where they dragged a paying
customer off their aircraft with a
broken nose broken teeth and a
concussion I feel sorry for every single
member of that crew because 100 of them
knew that that was the wrong thing to do
but none of them spoke up none of them
intervened because they feared getting
in trouble more than doing the right
thing
they did not work on trusting teams
this was not an anomaly this is a steady
build over the course of years that
eventually culminated in an event like
that
I was witness to a scene that played out
years before with United Airlines that
gave a flag that something was wrong
a scene played out in front of me as I
Was preparing to board a plane where one
of the passengers attempted to board the
aircraft before their group number was
called
which as you all know is a serious crime
and that is exactly how the gate agent
treated this passenger step aside sir I
haven't called your group yet please
step aside and wait till I call your
group as how she talked to a paying
customer
and so I spoke up
I said why do you have to talk to us
that way
why can't you talk to us like we're
human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said
sir if I don't follow the rules I could
get in trouble or lose my job
what she revealed to me is that she does
not feel safe in her own organization
her leaders do not trust her to do the
job for what she's been trained to do
and guess who suffers company customer
and her
the reason we love flying Virgin
Atlantic for example is not because they
have some magical formula to hire all
the best people
it's because the people who work there
feel safe in their own jobs they feel
trusted to do the job for which they've
been trained to do
and guess who benefits customer company
and the people who work there
it is a Leader's responsibility to set
an environment leadership is not about
being in charge leadership is about
taking care of those in your charge
leaders are not responsible for the
results they're responsible for the
people who are responsible for the
results and if you get the environment
right you get people like Noah
if you get the environment wrong you get
people like Noah
it's not the people it's the leaders
almost always when there are performance
issues almost always when there are
customer service issues it's so rarely
the people yes we have anomalies of
course
but if unbalance
you find that there's issues it's almost
always the leadership in the leadership
environment and usually it's the lack of
trusting teams the job of leadership is
to create trusting teams and if you want
to play in the infinite game you must
have trusting teams
one of the worst things about trusting
teams is how you build them because
they're not traditional in the sense
that we set a Target we're going to
build our teams of trust and we set out
to build them it's more of a practice
it's like getting into shape it's like
going to the gym yes you want to get
into shape unfortunately you can't go to
the gym for nine hours and get into
shape it won't work
but if you commit yourself to go to the
gym every single day for 20 minutes 100
you'll get into shape
Simon how long is it going to take me to
get into shape I don't know
and that's the problem someone some will
respond quickly and some will respond
slowly and there is no formula but we
all 100 know that the process works we
100 know that if you work out every
single day for 20 minutes and eat
healthily 100 of us will get into shape
it's the same in leadership there's no
five magical things that I can tell you
to do there's no one-day course you can
go take or one offsite you can have with
your team or all of a sudden they become
trusting teams yes those things are
important but they're part of a process
a process that we trust in that process
is called leadership leadership is a
lifestyle and even when you achieve your
goal even when you get into shape even
when the trusting teams are built
unfortunately you have to keep going to
the gym for the rest of your life
it's a lifestyle leadership is a
lifestyle and the purpose of that
lifestyle is to produce teams who take
care of each other who love each other
and feel valued and valuable in the
organization where they work that is
your job
thank you
[Music]